gosh all right here we are
yes gabrielle where are you from
originally uh temecula twice california
down by san diego kind of yeah
and uh
tell me what you found me growing up
um
my family was pretty average pretty
normal my parents split up when i was
around six or seven
um
wasn't anything traumatic or crazy they
just
weren't a good fit still had good
relationships with both of them um
yeah my childhood was pretty average i
guess didn't really do anything wasn't
too extravagant made through school yes
i graduated high school
and what'd you do after that um i ended
up
going to two years of school but college
was not for me it never was i wanted to
do it because my dad wanted me to have a
degree
so i ended up dropping out and leaving
and then pursuing what i actually wanted
to do which is tattooing that was right
so your childhood was good no no
terrible
no nothing crazy it was pretty average
up until like high school time and then
high school got a little wild but it
wasn't
home that was crazy it was school that
was crazy and friendships and you've had
you have some interesting relationships
it sounds like yes
tell me about them
well
in high school when i first started um
when i was
14 yeah 14 14 or 15
um i met a girl there who became my best
friend and i went to private schools my
whole life so i went to christian
schools and catholic schools this was at
a christian private school i met her we
became
best friends hung out every day i used
to go to her house after school because
my mom worked late so my mom would pick
me up from there
her mom was a meth addict or is i don't
know i don't talk to them anymore was a
meth addict for about 25 years at that
point
um
became best friends with that family her
house was
in shambles it was horrifying they
didn't have windows didn't have doors i
don't know
um
we ended up both being trafficked for a
little bit from her mom and then
the girl got expelled from our school so
i never saw her again last i heard she
was
a woman of the night prostituting
herself
in oklahoma
but i don't know anymore
um
yeah that relationship kind of
[ __ ] me up for a little bit
and then i got over it
high school was pretty normal and then
my senior year i met
my
ex-boyfriend his name was jessie
um
well i thought his name was jesse his
name was not jesse
we met i was 17 we met in september
october
of 2016
yeah and then
we were together until i was about
almost 19.
yeah
pretty
pretty crazy
what kind of things happened
um
well
how did it start oh
i don't know
let's see
how did it start
um
so we met through
family tree hold on
my best friend at the time her name was
justine
um
she was dating this kid named landon and
jesse was landon's roommate so he lived
with landon landon was our age he was 17
16 17. um justine was also 17 and jesse
was 21 or 22 at the time
um so red flag number one he was 21 or
22 dating a 17 year old um
i didn't see the red flag
at the time
but i see it now as a 22 year old i
would never date a 17 year old
but
it started he would come to
school plays and things of the sort with
landon to go support our friend justine
so i met him mutually we started hanging
out and then we got into a relationship
pretty quickly maybe like a month after
meeting and talking
yeah
it started out
smoothly
um
yeah it started out pretty okay it was
my first relationship so i didn't
i don't know i didn't really have
a basis of what i liked and what i
didn't like um or what was normal and
what wasn't normal um
so it started pretty normally and then
about
like five or six months in it started to
spiral
he
started telling me of these
delusions that he was having
that he was he thought he was god and he
thought he was the devil at the same
time and he thought he knew how the
world was going to end
and he thought that i was going to be a
part of it and i was some
priestess from a different life trying
to contact him i don't know some weird
spiritual [ __ ] that
became delusions that he believed um
yeah he moved in with my mom and i um
and marietta about
i want to say eight months into dating
it didn't it wasn't a definite like
oh like do you want to come live with us
it was he would stay with us for
weekends um i would pick him up because
he lived kind of far so i would go pick
him up he didn't have a car he didn't
drive he didn't have a license red flag
number two but
um i would go pick him up from his mom's
house and then
he would come to our house and stay for
like
like a weekend friday through sunday or
monday morning and then i would drive
him back and then
over the course of those like eight
months he started to just stay longer
durations of time
um and then he just slowly moved in
so it wasn't i don't know it wasn't the
healthiest way to go about it and i
definitely wouldn't have anybody living
with my parents now but
yeah those delusions kept progressing
they kept progressively getting worse
i used to do photography for musicians
and bands and such
and he would come with me to shows
and we would get home we would drive
home at like three four o'clock in the
morning
early nobody's on the road unless
they're you know commuting to work um
and we would drive home
and there'd be like one or two cars on
the road far behind us and
he would look at me seriously and say
um you know why these people are
following me they know what i am they
know what i'm capable of they know who i
am
delusions and i would
have to sit in the car and kind of agree
just in case i didn't want him to like
crash
but
yeah these delusions kept progressing he
um
yeah we it was hard it was hard to watch
someone like that you love so dearly
deteriorate
um into their own mind
but um
he
started cheating on me early on in the
relationship about a year in and
continued
um
i would catch him cheating all the time
it was as far as i know
it was only physical with a girl twice
maybe
um but a lot of it was through social
media and facebook and
email surprisingly but um i would catch
him cheating and catch these women that
he's talking to and sexting or just
talking to and it just
didn't sit right with me i would catch
him um
and i would show him the messages and he
would make me feel crazy and like it was
my fault
um and cry and scream and he would freak
out say that he was gonna kill himself
and then
everything was magically okay
but
yeah those um
delusions ended up getting sort of the
best of him he
threatened at some point to
kill me kill himself kill his family
he
got 51.50 and was held in a hold for
it was going to be 72 hours like the
standard hold and then it became like
three weeks
um
yeah the entire time his family was
talking to me they had no idea i existed
um i was a secret and that was already
like
a year and a half
almost two years into our relationship
red flag number three
big red flag it's a banner
red banner number three
um
i was a secret
he said he kept me secret because of my
age fair enough i guess i was
um i had just turned 18
um shortly after i graduated high school
that year so
you can justify anything
yeah do you find did you find yourself
justifying a lot of his behavior yes 100
excuses for it
100
um
there was a part of me that just wanted
to like fix it
and fix him and make it better
um
because a part of me you know saw his
delusions and realized well he can't
control it so it's not really
his fault he can't
you know they're involuntary what he's
feeling is involuntary and he fully
believes it he's immersed in it he hears
it he sees it
you know it's real to him
so
i don't know i
definitely justified it
and then when he was in the hospital
he was put on medication he was
diagnosed with severe paranoid
schizophrenia and depression and a few
other things
um but the schizophrenia was the main
problem
um
i think that yeah early 20s is the
the right age for that too i think so
yeah i think it started showing up
for him i'm i'm guessing earlier for
sure like
late teenager maybe like 16 17 um but
his family didn't really
put effort into caring for that he
definitely showed symptoms and signs
from the stories that he would tell me
what his friends would tell me
he when he was 21
or 20 before we had started before we
even knew each other um
he
had a delusion at his friend's house
they were drinking they were he was
super drunk and then he ended up having
sex with his friend's 14 year old sister
and i found that out
about a year and a half into the
relationship when he was in the hold his
family told me
red flag number five
he had sex with a 14 year old
that was traumatizing that was horrible
to hear
but
for some
unknown reason i still justified it
yeah he
in the hospital he was okay um i would
go visit him with my mom i would go
visit him with his mom once they found
out about me
and he was pretty okay he wouldn't
really say anything outlandish he seemed
to be acting docile and okay
but as soon as he was discharged he came
back to live with me my mom and i had
him on his medications i would give it
to him when he needed to like a
stay-at-home nurse
a whole 18 year old was a nurse um
and
he ended up one day just going cold
turkey and he stopped and he
went nuts
um
he ended up
putting his hands on me multiple times
continuously cheating
making me feel crazy
um
he would have sex with me in my sleep
um so
he would rape me
uh that was my first experience with sex
we waited until i was 18 and then he
would do it in my sleep
and then
yeah that yeah
i would call him out on it and he would
just tell me that this is what a
relationship is
you were supposed to have sex and this
was normal and that's just what he liked
i guess unconscious girls um
yeah
uh it was super
dehumanizing
but
yeah
i don't know i would wake up in the
morning and he would be staring over me
sometimes
and he would
like try to
tell me that i was doing something
sexual in my sleep to myself that's why
he did it to me like touching myself or
something and i definitely wasn't
um
you would know i would know
so he would try to justify it which made
me feel crazy
for calling rape on my boyfriend so i
never said anything
and as we kept going it just
got worse this relationship lasted how
long
i think it was like about
almost three years
just shy of three years and by the point
you're at the point you're describing
now what was your mindset with
everything i don't i was
i don't know are you still in love and
just like you know
i don't know
i think i was in love
no no
no
i don't know i don't know if it even was
love
to be honest because
i've been in love since and it didn't
feel like that and it wasn't like that
at all i don't know if it was just a
comfort thing someone was there
i was it was your first relationship
yeah i was comfortable with him he moved
in um
i think i just felt
comfortable
and i got too comfortable
and i allowed it
all of it um i later on found out that
his name wasn't really jesse his name
was jesus
his last name is hall
his last name in real life is not hall
so
he lied to me about his name i found out
through his birth mom we went once i
confronted him about that we went to go
meet his birth mom
and she is a meth addict she's on the
streets in west covina
um
sweet woman but
a slave to
meth
um
she i i don't know if like schizophrenia
runs in their family i don't know if
it's a genetic thing or if it's
hereditary i don't know how it all works
but
she used to have delusions and think
that she was some spiritual being and
see things and hear things i don't know
if that was the meth or if that was
schizophrenia or if that was both
but it definitely was there for both of
them they both believe the same things
so we used to stay with her
sometimes
and like hang out with her for the day
really awkward really weird
um
she was a she just constantly asked for
money couldn't find a stable job
couldn't find a stable home
in and out of rooms yeah it was a
it was a weird realization that he lied
to me about his life basically
but again i justified it because i
thought who would want to tell their
girlfriend that their mom is a meth
addict
um
yeah
so
yeah
so uh so what happened with this
relationship in the end um
well we so my mom and i had moved from
marietta to menifee um
we moved into a smaller home and jesse
came with us
so
we had moved everything was going oh i
mean wasn't going okay but it was going
about the same nothing had changed
drastically good or bad um
he had given me a promise ring
the christmas before we had moved
whatever um
and he was so sad that we were going to
get married in like the following year
it was super strange it was really fast
he had never mentioned any interest of
marriage until that moment so
i had gotten my first job at that point
i was 18 my first job i was working at
hot topic in our mall and it was a
seasonal job it was like christmas time
um or thanksgiving time and
he used to
follow me to work like i had a car he
didn't have a car so he would force me
to
drive us both to my job and he would
wait around
and make sure that i wasn't talking to
anybody make sure that i wasn't
interacting with any of my male
co-workers
if i didn't go with him to work i would
come home and he would tell me that i
smelled like i had had sex with someone
like
i guess the musk that you have when you
have sex told me that that's what i
smelled like all the time no matter what
so he just assumed that i was just a
[ __ ]
having sex with everybody that i met my
coworkers customers whoever
so
i got tired of it he started coming with
me to work
i had met my best friend at the time his
name was mason
um
and he
this kid jesse had isolated me from
everybody so i had like no friends so
going to work was my one getaway to go
talk to other people besides him and my
mom
um so i met this kid named mason and we
were inseparable we were best friends
he
we liked the same music we liked the
same things
his humor was contagious
it was an awesome relationship
a great kid he's still a great kid
and we met
hung out all the time
and then jesse started having an extreme
problem and then
having someone like mason who was so
healthy in his understanding and he was
a
he was an outsider he wasn't in my
relationship so he could
kind of see what was wrong
and
tell me like hey this isn't normal
um because my mom wasn't telling me that
so
you know
mason would tell me like this isn't
normal i would tell him when jesse would
hit me when jesse would assault me
when he would berate me i would send him
screenshots of our messages so he would
see the way jesse would talk to me and
he was like hey this is normal
so one day
mason and i went after work to go get
coffee we went to like a starbucks
[Music]
and we were sitting across from each
other at the table outside
and jesse texted me and he said i know
what you're doing and i was like what am
i doing
um and i told him i sent him a picture
of mason over here
and our drinks whatever
and he was like i know you're you're
[ __ ] mason in his car i know you're
sucking his dick blah blah blah et
cetera i'm getting graphic and i told
him that's not what i'm doing
i don't know what you you're thinking
like
it's really not what i'm doing i'm not
interested in him like that we're just
friends um
and then
he threatened he told me he was like i
can see you and i told him well how do
you see me you don't have a car how
could you get here my car is here
mason's car is here
i don't know how
you think you could come and see me and
he told me that he stole my mom's car
um he said that he had stolen my mom's
keys stolen my mom's car and he's around
the corner and he can see us
and i told him that i'm going to call
the police
that i know he didn't steal my mom's car
i had called my mom her car was still
home
he was still home so
that was
sort of the breaking point i i knew at
that point like it was like a switch
i looked at mason and i knew that this
is like how i had to leave and i had to
create like a plan to leave which is
dumb because he lived with me but i had
to create a plan to leave
without him knowing because god knows if
he knew that i was planning to leave he
would have done something
so
i got mason familiar with my family my
family loved him my mom and my dad loved
him so he became an integral part of the
escaping
i would
text jessie and tell him i'm going to a
friend's house i would go to mason's
house and i would bring some stuff with
me and i would
kind of stay
um
and i would have fights with jesse and
kind of detach and tell him
like we're done i'm over it but i
couldn't do it in person because he
would have probably killed me
so i kind of have to do it away
from him and everyone else but he
couldn't know where i was at because i
didn't want to put mason and his family
in danger
so
at one point i was with mason in my car
and jesse had called me and he was going
on
some delusion about
me being
the reason the world was going to end
and
he's the devil and this is why nothing
in his life works out
whatever the voices were talking to him
um
i had contacted his mom his real mom his
birth mom and then i had contacted the
mom that he was staying with
told them what was happening sent them
screenshots they didn't care his birth
mom was feeding into the delusions
so at that point
i sucked it up
i went home
and the next day i went on his
um
playstation and i found out that he was
cheating again and that was
that was it
i
grabbed his playstation and i went to my
backyard and i smashed it on the ground
and i took all his [ __ ] and i put it in
trash bags and i put it all on my
driveway
and i called his friend carla to come
pick him up and she did
um
i had already smashed his phone prior to
this
so
he didn't really have much he had a
laptop and that's how he would
communicate with me through facebook um
were you afraid for yourself i was very
afraid
yeah i was afraid i was more afraid for
my mom um because she didn't
deserve to deal with that but i i
brought crazy into her home
um
[Music]
about a month or two later about two
months later when everything was said
and done jesse had left i hadn't had
contact with him
in that amount of time i had changed my
number
um
i had done everything i could to get
away from him
i
uh mason and i kind of started talking
late like
very casual dating whatever
um jesse had found out i don't know how
i think through social media i think he
found mason's instagram and saw that
masonry posted a picture of us um
so at that point
jesse had contacted me again through
social media through a burner account
that he had made
saying that he needed to come pick
something up from my house
that he had left when i threw him out um
so he had come
he came to my mom's house picked me up
or not picked me up he came to my mom's
house um knocked on the door
um
i
uh i opened the door and
he was in a white button-down shirt and
slacks it looked like he was gonna go to
a wedding i think that was what he
needed i think he needed a suit
um
he was in white button down slacks nice
shoes and his sleeves were rolled up to
his elbows
and he was bleeding
from
he had cut himself from
like here to here
just straight down
planning to end it all he'd cut himself
and he was bleeding at the door
and i knew he just wanted sympathy
so i had
zero sympathy left for him i didn't give
a [ __ ]
so
i went inside i grabbed the suit that he
needed and i brought it back out to him
and shut the door in his face and that
was it
um
and he left and a few months later i had
heard from him
um again
just kind of threatening me
from different accounts he would make
different instagram accounts and
try and find me and threaten me and call
me a [ __ ] and whatever
um but
yeah that was a
that was a long
two and a half year relationship
at a really young age
you're lucky to get to have gotten out
of it
yeah i don't think i would have if i had
stayed even a month longer
he was getting really erratic he was
getting very frequent
where is he today or what happened after
that um
i don't know last i know he moved to
nevada with his friends
um
i had messaged his dad
who
is not his birth dad but i think it's
it's his uncle who raised him i messaged
him on facebook and i had told him maybe
in july this past july i had messaged
him and told him everything that had
happened and said hey like i'm getting
help but i want you to know that like
jesse did these things i don't know if
he has
a girlfriend right now but i feel like
he should
not have a girlfriend
um
and his dad just kind of said okay and
then ignored it so
i think jessie is in nevada he
is excused for all he does
nobody holds him accountable
so
yeah what lessons have you learned from
this
uh to not trust anybody uh for a long
time i just didn't want to trust anybody
even now um
it's hard
i have learned
that once there's one red flag to dip
because
after the fifth red banner
um
it's overwhelming there shouldn't be any
red flags
new especially not like that excuses for
this
yeah
it was
yeah i yeah
i had a friend at the time too i was 17
and she was 15 and her name was fable
and we used to hang out like every few
days every weekend
um and i introduced her to jesse and
jessie said that he really liked her
like romantically liked her should have
been
another red flag
because she was 15
but
yeah that whole relationship was a big
mistake and if i could go back and do it
all again i would
you would i would i would go back to
high school and put myself through that
to just not oh and not do not get
involved with him yeah yeah to ignore
him delete him block him just never see
him again
that'd be great are you are you
behaving
are you avoiding those kind of red flags
in other relationships you've had
um i think so i think i'm doing a better
job at regulating the red flag
basis
for the few years between
that relationship and the one i'm in now
i wasn't i was a mess i was everywhere i
definitely was looking for red flags
[Laughter]
[Music]
something
even now in the relationship i'm in it's
very normal and calm and something i
look for is chaos because i was so used
to that and it felt normal um
so i have to
dial it back now and you're still young
yet healthy i'm 22. 22. yeah i'm kidding
i am you learned a hard lesson at a
young age
yeah really hard lesson a really really
painful long lasting lesson
um yeah a first the first relationship
shouldn't be like that
no
i am
was a like a hopeless romantic i wanted
my first relationship to be at you know
high school sweethearts but
quite the opposite
not quite the opposite
all right gabriel thank you for sharing
your story
thank you hope that never happens to you
again yeah you know me too
thank you very much yeah thank you
you